we would like to acknowledge the
wonderful Academy Award show Orchestra
directed for the 17th time by Oscar
winner bill Conti okay some hit some
great news so far ten awards have been
given out and not one of the winners has
tested positive for steroids
okay so we're we're cool there now
please welcome comedy superstar Jeremy
Irons
so good to be recognized at last you
have to be careful who you say this to
in this in this tongue but there are
some movies that they're they're
wonderful they are maybe just a tad too
long I hope they missed
and then there are there are some that
are so good that we never want them to
end those often fall into this category
where brevity has its own rewards the
nominees for Best live action short
everything in this country must Jerry
McKendree little terrorist Ashwin Kumar
some 35 in the morning match over along
though two cars one night's title ITTF
Ainsley God was Andrea Arnold
and the Oscar goes to wasp and really
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Andrea Arnold this is
truly overwhelming I'm not really used
to this kind of thing I'd like to thank
everyone who worked on the film everyone
worked extremely hard they know who they
are and I'm the beers are on me when we
get home and what can I say in English
would say I'd say that this is the dog's
bollocks thank you very much
welcome two-time Oscar nominee Laura
Linney
a century ago when cartoonists Winsor
McCay drew his first animated cartoon he
drew it alone all four thousand cells
and pioneered the art of animation ever
since it has been an industry that has
amused billions of people in millions of
audiences in thousands of theaters and
hundreds of towns and led to awards like
the one I'm about to bestow the nominees
for best short animated film are
birthday boy
sejong Park and Andrew Gregory
go-for-broke
Jeff Fowler and Tim Miller
Lorenzo Mike Gabriel and Baker
Bloodworth
guard-dog Bill Clinton
Brian Chris Landrum
and the Oscar goes to Ryan Chris Lambton
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Chris Landry
I am here tonight because of the grace
and humility of one guy watching from
Montreal Ryan Larkin I dedicate this
award to you and I'm sharing this award
with Steve Hoban from copper hearts
entertainment Steve you and Mark Smith
were with me on this from the very
beginning you guys are troopers and to
Marcy Paige from the National Film Board
of Canada you guys are visionaries in
Canadian filmmaking to the Canada
Council for the Arts and Seneca College
Dave bass and my crew you guys know who
you are you're the most inspired and
dedicated people I have ever worked with
and to my darling Jodi I love you so
much and finally to the Academy for
continuing to support short filmmaking
in all its forms I cannot tell you how
cool that is